a part of Los Angeles this is screen
junkies movie finds now your host Andy
signor brought to you by t-mobile
now Netflix has included another reason
why t-mobile is America's best unlimited
network
good afternoon movie fine welcome to a
very special eighties themed movie
fights
I'm Alicia Malone host of this show and
author of the book that's out now called
backwards and in heels available am so
sorry had to get that blood in but today
we're gonna have so much fun because
we're gonna be talking about some great
fights including who gave the best
performances in the 1980s what movie was
the most influential and which eighties
film could work just as well today as it
did back then but first before we get
into all that they're here how fighters
the sporos the Motorhead's the geeks the
[ __ ] the Bloods the wastoid it's the
dweebies and the [ __ ] all think
she's a righteous dude movie download
and a movie bytes favorite session
forever I am so excited about this this
is so great first of all it's super
super super stoked at your hosting I
love it second that it's just 80s all
day when we all win we all win because
this is we're gonna talk about some of
my favorite movies ever and I cannot
wait I cannot wait to hear what you guys
have second up he's the writer of Holly
and Ivy meet Betty and Veronica he has a
head for business and a bod for sin and
there's nothing wrong with that mr.
Macha
take that line muck and finally she's
the host of six degrees of feature film
but nobody puts brand Chandler in the
corner hi hello how are you doing good
thank you so much for coming thank you
this is my first time fighting I will be
gentle with you and where we're going we
don't need roads but we do need a fact
checker so from Fandango please welcome
Jack Hynes
hi guys how are you show me a glove
oh you want to see my thank you I
appreciate it and on the fan cam she's
about to see things you people wouldn't
believe it is Candice welcome very glad
I got an excuse we're Mike colorful
clothing yes thank you so much for
dressing up I really really appreciate
it
so a quick rule reminder before we get
started it's about creativity it's about
passion it's not which I personally
think is the best choice and so just
have fun with it you know let's you
don't have to be afraid be very afraid
I'm gonna keep going with let's get into
it roll the clip cue the music
by the time that ten fights
I know I've been all Rocky's look at our
logos yeah yeah see some oh my god looks
like nice flight I love it it's so cold
so Rachel to one what 80s movie which
never got one actually deserved a sequel
we're gonna start with you Sasha please
tell us your choice in your opening
argument all right I feel like there are
a lot of movies that we've seen sequels
were that we didn't want one I would
have loved to have seen was The
Breakfast Club there was actually one
planned there were a number of them
planned but John Hughes and Jed Nelson
had a falling out John he's also was not
a fan of doing sequels but think about
this you had the brain a beauty a jock a
rebel and a recluse we only spent nine
hours with them and we were so touched
by their lives I want to know what
happened did they shun Anthony Michael
Hall in the hall on Monday what happened
with Emilio and Ashley an ally are they
still together did Judd and Molly
somehow make it work or was that earring
the last moment that they spent there
are so many unanswered questions there
are so many strings that were left open
they talked about going 10 years into
the future and then doing future sequels
that way but you could have done it the
next day and I would have followed it
you can do it 35 years from now which
will be on February 15 2020 and I would
still totally follow it and yes we no
longer have John Hughes but we have so
many directors that were heavily
influenced by him like Cameron Crowe was
coming up at the same time like you
could say I mean I don't think this
would be the perfect answer but Judd
Apatow but why not get Carencro out of
that horrible sort of Elizabeth ship
town Aloha world that he's been living
in take him back to the stuff that we
loved so much or get Chris Columbus
Chris Columbus who hasn't done a movie
like this in a really long time
I would totally watch that but even if
they don't when I think about the movies
that left me with a million unanswered
questions The Breakfast Club is number
one loving Claire Claire Claire muck I
picked a friend something that should
have been a franchise and I think there
were rights tie up so I think there was
this was almost announced a couple times
but I think Alton we call it The Last
Starfighter
because the last starfighter if you want
to see how to do a Green Lantern movie
do the last starfighter it's exactly
everything Green Lantern should have
been and it ended with Lance guest:the
who played the lead kid and Robert
Preston and his last performance before
he died it was also so wonderful in
victor/victoria and he was the original
Harold Hill and The Music Man but it
ended with him being starting up the
star fighting group again and it was
just it was just it was made for a part
- coming out next summer and also it was
one of those movies there's a big-budget
special effects movie but it has so much
heart because it takes place on earth
for most of it
he lives in a trailer park with his
divorced mom and his little brother and
it's a very it's almost a character
piece and then when they bring this
otherworldly part in because he gets
recruited by playing the videogame and
aliens are checking the videogame to see
who gets the best scores to be their
pilots because why not it feels very
much like a Spielberg movie but not
trying to be a Spielberg movie it's one
of those movies that you could watch
with you all your family from your
grandfather down to a baby and they
would all enjoy it for different levels
and it's really been kind of forgotten
and deserves a Renaissance because I
think we see so many movies that are
wall-to-wall special effects these days
and this was a movie that had you cared
about the characters that's the special
effects made the story more important if
they weren't these story loved it
breanne my choice is Big Trouble in
Little China now it's I'm gonna give a
little bit of a spoiler because at the
end of Big Trouble in Little China we
see that there's a monster on the back
of the porkchop Express and Jack Burton
has no idea that it is there so I want
to know what is going to happen with
that monster I saw this for the first
time maybe two years ago and I was just
shocked that it ended in this
cliffhanger and I had no there was no
you know solution I thought where is the
next movie why didn't I get another
movie why can't I find out what happens
what is he gonna do now is he gonna get
home is that monster gonna be with him
at home
is it gonna sneak up on him at some
point is gonna meet his family does he
have a family
what there's so many questions about
Jack Burton in general I would love to
see him take on this beast is there more
than one beast awesome open
go for it well you talk about this is a
film that should've been a franchise
this film kind of is a franchise it's
guardians of the galaxy it is Green
Lantern how many space operas do we need
at a certain point it's like are we
talking about it right now or are we
talking about it back then is my
question to Lady judgy because let's say
back then what should have gotten a
sequel yes he still had Star Wars you
still had we were about to go into like
you've got Back to the Future you have
so many other films that's like whether
the navigator you've got you've got a
wargames
but that's like comparing that Beverly
Hills cops to Serpico they're both about
cops this vlog breathless couple we had
Porky's is this deep story about these
teenagers that remains one of the most
influential teen comedy dramas of all
time and it wrapped up in a nice little
package sighs don't we know what happens
because I don't want to be depressed
about when they hate each other
come Monday and they don't talk to each
other again there's no way you honestly
don't want to know what happened you
definitely not only what happened
Anthony Michael Hall became an alcoholic
because he was a closeted crabs be
pregnant and dropped out according to
the deleted extra scene as janitor
talked about it actually in siddhim
alcohol was extremely successful yeah he
was a starter but had a heart attack so
he died because no Florida super girl
cause he was working so hard to achieve
the success that to cover up with his
closeted message so people would like
him I feel like it's still a movie that
talks about relevant issues we don't be
carries about going to space we have a
million people going to space but
everybody deals with high school and
everybody deals with confronting who you
really are then nobody likes space what
are the top groceries a lot I've never
been able to make it through Big Trouble
in Little China Big Trouble in Little
China and buckaroo banzai are two movies
that have cults that I just don't
respond to that doesn't mean they're bad
it's just not my cup of tea I feel about
Big Trouble in Little China though that
all these 80s genre movies that were on
the lower end of the scale all ended
with a cliffhanger like
wishful thinking like there was a movie
called sword in the sorcerer that said
this guy will return and the heart of
demons or something like they earned a
sequel felt like they were saying please
please we want to come back in six
months and I just think the last
starfighter like I said about Spielberg
how it has a Spielberg and touches it's
a human story the same way that ET is
about a family this is about a family
and I think I think it humanizes we see
so many space movies that are all set in
the future are different galaxies this
makes it relate to us not me 80s we
didn't fly to the Navigator was
present-day war games was present-day
games isn't an alien invasion movie it's
about a computer and then this is great
but this is about a computer game that
brings aliens to America so that they
can find a great fighter and war games
was about using a computer game to find
a great fighter and fight a fight that
people do are they worth fighting that's
a stretch that's a stretch putting them
far as big trouble a little trainer I
feel like it's the Kurt Russell effect
but we got escaped from New York we got
escaped from LA I think that yeah skate
from LA is the biggest warning sign
about why we shouldn't have a Big
Trouble in Little China too and there's
so many things about that movie where
first of all maybe it's just because I'm
watching it through the van of now but
do we need another white Savior movie in
the Asian culture
oh he deals drugs in the sequel so
ultimately I do think Breakfast Club is
an amazing movie but I think it is much
like the Graduate and much like a lot of
other important movies like that we
don't need a sequel what we imagine
those kids fates are is going to be much
more satisfying than anything that was
ever written it's the it's the curse of
knowing too much about characters no Jon
Bender's in prison that's what happened
in that epilogue that you were talking
about with them isn't that because if no
water was applicable
I think workable but you said you said I
couldn't think about the other side
you guys are so famous that you would
like to you and John Hughes who was one
of the greatest directors of the
eighties curly sue who wanted to do
films every 10 years with this cast who
saw that as a vision this is the guy who
gave us Ferris Bueller's Day Off
who gave us sixteen Candles and you gave
us breakfast club you're like Meg
vision kind of sucks is that what you're
telling me no I'm sorry that's all I
know I do you see she sucks I said I've
said that movie is perfect the perfect
the way it is so they don't mean she
want anything else would diminish the
power of that movie I think you're
completely wrong that's like saying the
Godfather didn't need a sequel - did you
see / - one of the best sequels ever
what do you think about last stuff I
said oh the last start okay so here's my
question cuz I can't remember and I
again this is a movie that I saw maybe
two months ago so I want to know does he
leave his girlfriend behind I can't
remember no he comes back he comes back
and takes her with him okay so it's just
the story is little brother is left on
earth and we the last thing we see is
the so you come back for the sequel you
know not that Lance gets back down would
get a lot of money but if he was being
difficult you haven't get killed and the
brother takes something takes it on and
you just expand that you know then do we
call it the last Last Starfighter that's
what I watch the sequel title you can
change the titles we call star wars star
wars - we call an eclair story are we
talking about okay well alright change
isn't so that's subtitle underneath okay
final thoughts about why H of us
deserved as they go back then I think
that you had five of the biggest stars
at the time you had one of the greatest
directors of the decade there was only
like I said one day spent with these
characters they lived entire lives I
want to know what else happened I think
we deserved that I still would like to
see them when I saw them get together at
the MTV Movie Awards I was like exciting
their stories are so relatable
everything about what they're talking
about
everything about what they deal with I
think is a template for not just teenage
life but human nature in general and
anything that John Hughes would have
given us I know would have been
brilliant and I feel deprived that we
didn't get exact laughs I said well I
didn't know we got to pick the directors
for our sequels because that changes
things if John Hughes were to make if
John he was made a sequel it's he
created it so it's his to mess up the
same way George Lucas did with the
prequels to Star Wars you can't complain
about that because he created all that
stuff if we're going to pick directors
that's a whole change of the story but
that wasn't the question I got so last
starfighter feels like the one that has
the best of both worlds it's got special
effects like this and some really great
performances and like The Breakfast Club
it's got a really human story underneath
all the big outerspace stuff it's about
this kid trying to find himself and
dealing with his divorced mom was kind
of erect and trying to figure out who's
what his place in the world is now he
finds a place in the universe I think
this is the best this movie is a is a
bouillon cube of what's great about a
lot of the eighties movies
all right PM cube very nice well I just
want to say that the story of Big
Trouble in Little China and Jack Burton
is one that we continue to come back to
that rock was signed on at some point to
do you know a reboot of it there has
been a comic that has come out that is
old man
Jack that is by carpenter and oh they've
had Jack Burton meet Snake Plissken
exactly wouldn't love that but basically
this story is something that people want
to know and one and want to be continued
to be told they want to know more about
Jack and I want to know more about Jack
and I want to know more about that guy
on the back of his truck and I want to
see the porkchop Express again before we
decide Jack any facts to clear up or
anything to add Sasha I mean a lot of
people were calling Sasha in the comment
section on that one I give you that one
cetera so you should definitely read
back through they were very torn on
Breakfast Club yeah a lot of people were
saying absolutely no way Jose and a lot
of people were saying yes let's go for
it it seemed as though a few of the the
movie experts piped up during the last
style fighter and a lot of them are
going like oh this one really came outta
left field and took it quite nicely but
according to the comments I think big
trouble one little time it's pretty a
lot of people agree people would love to
see the story of Jack Byrne however
everybody's very mad nobody bought up
Spaceballs wanting for a while moving
all right well I feel the need the need
for speed choose the winner
and each winner gets one of my bracelet
wanting to see more from the group in
those stories those pieces and just
wanting to find out even if it was the
next day or the next day but you know I
want to see five years and I yeah I
think that that argument was talking
about the kinds of oh all right well
that's time for round two which 80s
movie would have the biggest success if
it were released in its identical format
as a new movie in theaters this year we
are starting with Brienne oh it's me I'm
going first so I chose the Princess
Bride yes the world right now is in
chaos and there's natural disasters
there's natural disasters politically
happening yeah I mean I'm not talking
about back then I'm talking about right
now because we're bringing this here to
this time but we want a way to escape
and we want something that's accessible
for everyone and I find that the
Princess Bride is a movie that is
accessible for all audiences and with
Game of Thrones this would really be the
time the right time to bring it to an
audience that is ready for it I think
especially because this movie has 97
percent on Rotten Tomatoes as an 8.1
rating on IMDB and it just has so many
likable characters and I find that it's
something I would like to see again
inconceivable there were a bunch of
these that I looked at I like you know I
looked at obviously like Back to the
Future and that sort of thing but Back
to the Future being released today is so
set in the 80s that you me don't need
context I think the movie that would be
the biggest hit if it opened today
unchanged will be James Cameron's aliens
I think that much like you said we're in
political chaos right now in the world's
very tense the success of it has shown
that's a reflection of our own
nervousness horror movies tend to do
well when there's times of great unrest
with Night of the Living Dead back in
Vietnam and stuff like that so this is
this is a funhouse ride in a haunted
house ride and it's terrifying and it's
scary and it's got great performances
all the way around Paul Reiser's great
in it the late Bill Paxton is fantastic
Michael Biehn of course Sigourney Weaver
what about the first genre Oscar
nomination maybe since Frederick Marx
got nominated from dr. Jekyll and mr.
Hyde in the 30s that was a huge deal
that she got an Oscar nomination in a
stupid outerspace movie and that movie
still holds up because Cameron used so
many practical effects for those aliens
it wasn't CG you saw how bad CG can be
an alien 3 the Fincher version because
it wasn't real but in this these actors
are acting opposite and this movie like
you said has this has a lot of heart to
it the whole maternal thing and one of
the cutscenes from aliens we find out
the Sigourney Weaver's daughter died of
old age when she was coming back from
outer space that was for the whole nude
thing but all that stuff Lance Henriksen
get away from her you [ __ ] I mean the
whole movie is because it's set in the
future and set in an alternate world it
is not dated at all and every single
character in that movie has a backstory
you you look even if they don't tell it
to you there's a plate with such
authority that it's the best of both
worlds it's this great rollicking
science fiction horror film and it's a
movie with this character study it's a
war movie as well it's just it's just as
it's mom one of my favorite if not my
favorite James Cameron Fox
Oh Sam session so everybody's talking
about how the world in chaos and with
something like it we really need
escapism that is part of the emotional
catharsis of a horror film there is no
better horror film within the shrining
and I to prepare for this i rewatch the
trailers for all three of these movies
and when you watch The Shining every
single shot holds up every single moment
holds up you're looking at it and you
can think of it as a film that was just
shot as a period piece that it was just
a directors choice sort of like if Wes
Anderson had a severe mental breakdown
and came back and decided to do this
twisted crazy film but you look at
everything from the carpet which is
still so iconic to the moment where you
see the twins or the Redrum it is still
so scary nothing about it feels dated
nothing about it feels like it's lost
step with the time
it is profoundly frightening so if what
we want is emotional catharsis there is
nothing better than goober training all
right open forum okay so I just want to
know how would that work how it taking
aliens and putting it into this time
work in terms of the franchise does it
are you saying we're getting rid of
everything or does alien 3 now become
alien 2 and then resurrection become the
third one and then Prometheus no I'm
just the we the question was what movie
if we lifted it from that original
release day and released at the same
thing but we still have a franchise I
know that you're moving it but at the
same time we had still had a lot of it's
also got a lot of bad well you've got a
lot of like hey man but covenant hey
that wasn't the question the question
was what individual film moved today if
it was released today would be a big
success it wasn't about sequels it was
you both have issues with CGI because
yes he did a lot of practical effects
but you know that a camera in every
released aliens he would give his grubby
avatar paws all over them what you good
book or avatars we see the exact same
film eats out teen film today it looks
dated it does and I love the Princess
Bride Hotel orange looks like it's about
Thrones in a world where we have Game of
Thrones I actually don't think that you
could release the princess bride because
when you look at like the cliff climbing
moment it's almost like a Batman
throwback when you and I'm talking the
Adam West Batman when you see the fight
she lives on top of the cliff it looks
like a high school play there are so
many moments and I love this movie but
you think that like the Carol Kane Billy
Crystal makeup holds up in 2017 it
doesn't that's not really the point of
that movie the movie is a fairy tale and
everything's heightened
at no point then you have you know the
the Lord of the Rings of this world
audiences wouldn't buy into it they'd be
like that looks incredibly cheesy they
wouldn't buy into it if you look at the
trolley so cannot not buy into the
shining because Stephen King is on
Twitter and you know what he's gonna be
like I don't like this and I'm not okay
with crazy about that movie is Stanley
Kubrick's version of The Shining is like
a shiny new car with no engine so when
the creator of that is alive and talking
smack about it I don't think people
really know the guy who wrote this book
we like I'm gonna go see the movie
there's nothing like it
faithfulness to the book how many books
are actually faithful how many how many
times you find the source material
actually paid all the Princess Bride is
faithful because William Goldman was
also did the screenplay
great that's known to have anything to
do with the visuals that has to do with
the story what I'm saying is is you can
see the scene was like we're saying I'm
sorry I'm telling you if you rewatch the
shining there is not a single moment
where every jump that you're supposed to
have doesn't still exist that the acting
is still profoundly impactful Jack
Nicholson at his best putting anybody
who's working right now to shame and the
look of it you have to think about the
visuals all the CGI because Cameron
doesn't care about looks like movies at
all he just issues with your film I
wonder what do you think about the
shining I just want to know like if
we're gonna move a movie to this time
how does that work in this time because
Kubrick is not with us anymore so did we
find it in some vault somewhere like and
oh hey yours antics you have to go to
semantics on this question like this yes
you do this movie gets released let's
say it's Kubrick is like I don't know
I'm not known whatever we don't always
dead if you just look at the movie if
you somebody just found this footage
this is a found footage situation and
you unspooled
all three of these movies do I think
that all of them would have impact
absolutely I think aliens would probably
be more successful than The Princess
Bride
but the shining there is no part of that
movie that you can look at and go I know
this was definitely shot in the 80s like
there's nothing about that it could be a
if you're bringing it out today how does
that play in terms of being up against a
movie like it which is another Stephen
King property so that means that
audiences are hungry for it and they're
gonna lap it up because there's what
because what there's multiple Marvel
movies so we can only have one there are
just like I just think of the three I
think that one is going to be the most I
think it's gonna be the most especially
today because it's aliens was the
biggest hit of these three one that
initially came out and still holds up
today and it's a roller coaster ride
kind of movie that people want that The
Shining is legitimately a scary movie
but it's a hard-r movie it's a very
disturbing movie and it's not going to
have the sort of success that it would
have all shining are about the same the
contrary as hamburgers in ice cream
brand final thoughts I feel like with
aliens though you kind of we see that
with avatar and we see some of those
same visuals so then we'd be seeing
those again but I do want to say you
know this movie The Princess Bride
teaches us something that is long-lost
and that is that good things come to
those who wait
inigo montoya waited 20 years to finally
get to the man the six-fingered man and
Wesley and Buttercup had to wait five
years apart I don't know why he didn't
send her a letter or something but you
know what I feel like that's a skill
that we are not seeing anymore on camera
time duck any facts to check in Peru our
lineup the YouTube comments
I will go word-for-word quote though
mark give me a split second how you
doing Candice okay you're tying it that
one gave me a lot of okay okay sir in
1985 empty with Craig moderno King says
Stephen King says it's like a great big
gorgeous car with no engine so somebody
JD on youtube did say that the shining
would be received similar to the way
mother has this year I'm just saying
Candace what do you think about how much
I would like to say I was hoping someone
would bring up mother not that they're
the same but I think people are very
turned off to that right now is like
being perceived as artsy aliens i watch
for the first time last year because I
finally convinced myself it wasn't too
scary did you enjoy I loved it and it
doesn't seem decades-old at all to me
alrighty so yes I had my quotes as
inconceivable again so don't forget that
and here only now it's lovely lime-green
fun storming the castle I think the
person that gave the most compelling
argument about why this movie would be a
success if it were released today in the
wider sense of the term is Mach and
Drake
[Applause]
1.1.2 mark
breanne still not yet to go in the
ballpit I've got plenty of time because
one guys what was the most influential
popular movie of the 80s and Mark you
get to stand there were a handful of
them and I think that when my two
competitors reveal theirs I think that
all of these are influential which is
always great the best movie fights are
always when all the movies legitimately
have their close like that but I picked
a movie that not only changed the pay
structure in Hollywood it broke down the
walls between TV actors and film actors
and was the most influential action film
maybe of all time which was die hard
because you saw that was a movie where
people knew who Bruce Willis was kind of
from moonlighting and then they went and
saw it and the movie just brings you and
everything that they didn't get in the
sequels right they got right here the
everyman
caught in this situation dealing with
his wife you know the whole the whole
movie would even Ola terrorist was about
him getting back together and bringing
his family together it was once again
family is so important in these movies
of the 80s or such a strong message
about it and if you look at all the
other movies the action movies that came
out for 10 years after that it was die
hard on a boat every single movie the
only thing that was dealing that was
lodged more than die hard in film for 10
years was morphing after Terminator 2
where was in everything die hard is one
of those action movies that is not only
exciting and thrilling and visceral but
the script is really great you've got
you've got on the late blanking his name
performance morning Weaver getting an
Oscar nomination for aliens he should
have gotten a Best Supporting Actor
nomination in this movie when he falls
and Bruce Willis sees him and he goes oh
I'm one of the American guys and Bruce
Willis gives them a cigarette and you
don't know if Bruce Willis knows he's a
spy there's so much small cleverness
within the script and the characters but
to go with the big blowing up stuff the
stuff with with Reginald veljohnson and
the Twinkies and and Argyll the the the
chauffeur Bonnie Bedelia was great the
smarmy guy and gets shot there's so many
real characters in this movie and thus
when you have a real care
the the Theia the circumstances are real
and you can you really feel when these
characters get hurt or get injured and
it's just it's just an all-around great
movie that you can watch it's like one
of the best Christmas movies of all time
as well
alrighty Brienne all right uh the movie
that I selected I'm I did a lot of notes
on I called Scott mance hi really this
but this is Blade Runner and Blade
Runner as we know it did give birth to
tech-noir sub-genre and it shows the
gloomy Los Angeles of 2019 and it's
pretty accurate to what it is today if
you look at LA live in downtown and it
gained its popularity mainly on home
video because at the time it didn't do
so well the box office it was up against
ATT and I find that it just shows it's
influential in that it's it mirrors a
lot of what is actually happening today
and it was voted best science fiction
film ever made in a poll of 60 eminent
world scientists conducted in 2004 by
the BBC News and it's been cited as
inspiration and then style and story for
ghost in the shell' as well as BAU star
Galactica and us I come meat I mean I
could mention every single movie that
it's ever influenced and it would
probably we'd be sitting here for quite
some time but it was also selected for
preservation in the US National Film
registry in 1993 and is frequently used
in university courses and it's one of
the most musically sampled movies as
well
[Music]
so I'm gonna throw out some bud
buzzwords for you guys okay
psychological complexity dark tones a
gritty retelling how many of those words
get movies green let these days all of
them and where did it start in 1989 with
Tim Burton's Batman if we're talking
about true influence you would not have
the Dark Knight if we didn't have
Keaton's tortured Bruce Wayne or
Nicholson's incredible Joker we would
not up until now you have to remember
that Batman was kerpow and like me me me
me me and it was tights not Kevlar not
armor everything was primary
it was pop this changed everything
also you're talking about TV guys going
to film Keaton was a comedy guy who
nobody expected to see in this kind of
role and what does that sound like that
sounds like Marvel's model that's what
Marvel has now done with Jon Favreau
with Robert Downey jr. with Taika
Waititi etc it also changed how
merchandising and marketing was done
forever the movie made insane money but
the franchising made five hundred
million in three years and that's what
was like actually licensed not what was
just bootleg they created a different
way to market film to make film and if
you want to talk about influence how
about every single DC and Marvel film
that we now get across every year how
about all of the the TV Empire that is
on ABC and Netflix for Marvel how about
DC's literally there's one show a week
on CW because of Greg Berlanti and it
all started with Tim Burton 1989 Batman
hey I've been for him okay just because
he turned off the lights
[Laughter]
iron is totally true
that is why diehard is a good movie that
is not white I heart is the most
influential movie and I love played
Runner and I can't wait for Blade Runner
2049 but you're like it was the
inception of tech Newar because there's
so many tech new are films that we see
kind of like the matrix
that's three movies give me smart I was
one of gosh I mean I could go what
Minority Report Fifth Element
Terminator okay so definitely terminator
how about the 17 billion dollars made by
superhero movies in the last 15 years
yeah but you but you're forgetting a
couple of things with that one you said
the Tim Burton brought this dark Batman
actually Tim Burton didn't he read Frank
Miller's The Dark Knight Returns and
Alan Moore and Brian Vaughn's The
Killing Joke and those were direct
influences on his
are you gonna say I love when you make
my argument I said you're you flatter
yourself hon I said they were influenced
by Frank Miller and they were not direct
adaptations at all if you look at the
source material in fact the closest to
Frank Miller's Dark Knight that we had
was actually Zack Snyder's Batman vs
Superman you talk about you talk about
the no you talk about the influence that
Batman had and it did for a very short
period of time and then Batman Forever
and Batman or Robin came out and they
were and they stopped making superhero
movies for a very there was a draw and
Batman Returns was a huge disappointment
that's why Tim Burton was not allowed to
go back for the Batman movie we have
seen starting with Batman Begins takes
direct correlation to the 1989 Batman
Ledger oscar-winning performance would
have ever happened if we hadn't had Jack
Nicholson's version of the Joker no way
how can you say that that's ridiculous
you have no idea because it's a
performing team doesn't look just
performing didn't carries the Riddler so
I can make a direct it's like they're
this and then there's this thing that's
good we got ice whatever with
Schwarzenegger what would see the Iceman
of the snowman right the heart that's
all real cute and everything but mal
wieder Anna well I think Blade Runner
art direction wise has influenced us
greatly and I think the dystopian future
in the rain and the rust which I hope we
don't ever see again because it got done
to death so I would like to see a happy
Jetsons future for once everybody's
rusty and wearing dirty dungarees in the
future thanks to that [ __ ] movie um I
think the movies better I respect that
movie more than I enjoy it watching that
movie it's not a great movie it's kind
of dull and kind of dry and look it
works there's a reason to talk off at
home video because it works better at
home because it's a very small noir
story I think I I just I think of all
these three movies which one would I
want to watch the most this one diehard
influenced an entire Jean
only in genres and years only influenced
to genre who wears Blade Runner
influenced all of film as well as
filmmakers man is there film that is a
direct correlation outside of the
children of men
Kenneth Turan of the LA Times called
children of men the Blade Runner of the
21st century okay so I've got Batman the
Justice League Black Panther
Wonder Woman Thor Thor Ragnarok I cannot
include the Marvel movies go to 89 to
actually crazy
I want to hear just final thoughts about
die hard
influences genre anything else you want
to add to that well she's just gonna cut
the optional alright well the reason why
Blade Runner is the most influential is
because is the clearest view of what the
world would look like and does look like
artificial intelligence is on the way to
getting to this point and it's
terrifying and this movie
maybe the reason why we question moving
forward with artificial intelligence in
the real world
Jack so you going crazy during that well
yeah I'm not gonna like personally a lot
of the things I strongly disagreed with
what sesor was say I'm gonna catch up
real quick from the last two rounds on
the first round watch 80s movie that
never what the most deserve sequel Big
Trouble in Little China wins it with 43
second place is back for his club in 32
places the last firefight with 25 round
to physics biggest success aliens 43 30%
for this shining 27% for this Princess
Bride pretty close very close so father
will be very close like with a really
good movies well suppose you venture
public movies at the eighties for this
round do you and that now would I wait I
gotta remember to come back to you and I
just had a free Freud YouTube know like
this is the best fire ever like blah
blah people were just cracking up it was
so entertaining and it was four hundred
and eleven million that Batman made not
fun no no I
it was in my
Marketing in 1992 it made 500 million in
merchandising off of just the things
that it licensed all right so that was a
tough ground all really good choices you
know I like what you said about the
genre was die hard is still being
referred to as die hard honor things I
had in yeah we spoke about you know
bringing back the psychological aspect
of that man and making a darker tone and
also the creation of Michael Keaton as
he went from this comedy guy to to
another serious role but the person that
gets a little bracelet he pointed out
wider than just the film industry what
kind of influence flavor and it has had
the way it's being taught in university
courses the way that it is influenced so
many movies right down to children of
men and of course we have another Blade
Runner coming out soon so I think that
everything you said means that it was
the most influential popular movie of
the 80s according to your argument don't
start mounts proud yeah yeah words I
don't ever want to hear I wonder if in
the sequel to Blade Runner they have all
the companies that don't exist that were
in Blade Runner like nobody Atari but I
wonder of all those companies like the
work they seem to have yeah you think
but yeah they seem to be using ones that
come from sony sony said marilla
needless so that means that we've got
one point to everyone which means they
can go anywhere and Brienne will have
what your heaven because that was a good
friend
let's go to Round four have to insert my
quotes what mediocre eighties movie are
sorry jack
sorry this is my bad who was at the poll
over on Twitter out poll we had in last
place with 27% Blade Runner Oh 31%
Batman and first place rate but whopping
42 percent
oh and I always forget about the
audience it's not like a 12% and then
everybody else has got like 70 all right
let's go to round 4 which mediocre 80s
movie has benefited the most from
nostalgia oh we're back we're all
getting ready for the hate for our
choices this is a film that didn't just
stick to 80s nostalgia it also spoke to
50s nostalgia which was a really big
thing
in the 80s and that is a Christmas story
a Christmas story which again if you
also want to think about nostalgia this
film's trajectory is so fascinating
because it was released right before
Thanksgiving in 1983 and no one cared
about it and then they started showing
it on television and it was owned by
Turner Ted Turner owned it so he put it
on his channels TMT or TNT TMC and TBS
and he just show it because he needed
something to fill holiday time and
people were trapped at home with their
families and needed something to escape
with and it became this movie and it
became so successful just because of
people's experience of it that now
there's 24-hour marathons of it and
people quoted all the time like
constantly when I get something in the
mail like friend juillet it must be
Italian and it's because of this not
that good and movie that was had no big
stars it was like this random Canadian
production and somehow because we've
grown up and it was just forced down our
throats we have memories of it at the
holidays we think of it at Christmastime
like I mean most you guys don't know
that there's a movie called my summer
story I do know that it was up for a
part in that
Twitter because I don't know how many
people know about my son
Marvin Draco Draco is your stinking
phone I'm telling you these are the only
two people in the world but before we
had Netflix before we had Hulu before we
had 500 channels we needed a holiday
movie and it became this and now I have
to see this film you're not at a
Christmas Story what's your choice um
I'm ready to probably lose this because
I know the Internet's gonna go insane
when I say that this is a mediocre movie
that there's way too much nostalgia for
it's a fine movie but the people that
worked on this movie did much better
movies and much funnier movies together
I've got to say ghostbusters
ghostbusters ghostbusters like you said
with with his Christmas driving shove
down our throat ghostbusters all of us
who were kids when we saw it we were
remembering it to the eyes of being 12
years old and if you're watching it when
you're 12 years old there's a couple of
jokes yes true it's true that manny has
no dick and all that stuff and there's
some fun special effects in it but
overall it's just kind of a it's just
kind of a flaccid moving there's you
know there's there's moments of fun but
it just it's just not as good as the sum
of its parts and then we in the
nostalgia was crazy the nostalgia bred a
whole generation of people that don't
like girls because of ghostbusters
the toxicity that came out from that
that alone makes me want to meet
ghostbusters never to be discovered
again goes you know if you look at the
Bill Murray Ivan Reitman held ramus
things meatballs holds up meatballs is
hysterically funny stripes is their best
collaboration by far you watched our
Groundhog Day there are so many other
movies that they all did together that
we're better this movie felt like they
were having a lot of fun but it felt
sort of like the most recent wet hot
American summer it felt like the people
making it we're having a lot more fun
than I was watching it
all right Brianne all right I probably
am also going to get a lot of hate for
this as well I'm choosing the Little
Mermaid the Little Mermaid's held up by
its core and its songs
but fails to hit the mark that Hans
Christian Andersen had created while
watering down the story to fit all
audiences the Disney version of the film
makes Ariel only good for one thing and
that's being a lovesick teenager who
defies her father and as a parent I
really dis disapprove of this I mean I
will say but the nostalgia that holds up
is the songs and it's definitely every
single piece of merchandise that comes
out of Disney there is so much from
Disney that is based around this
character my daughter knew who Ariel was
before even seeing the movie because of
the fact that she's on every single
piece of clothing she's at Target she's
available for people that are my age to
wear as well I'm probably gonna be
dressing up as no no my goodness there's
parades there's rides there's Ariel's
Grotto where you can go and have dinner
with her which we have done he's
probably there preparing it as well and
the musical which took the stage in 2007
and closed in 2009 having over 600
performances so there's a lot that goes
along with this a lot to sell
merchandise and the fact that you get
two princesses in one is great for
Disney so you get you know the fish
Ariel as well as the on land Ariel so
there's a lot of toys to be sold
okay hit the mark that Hans Christian
Andersen yeah because his very on here
only being there the server purpose
because of her voice in because she's
there for a man she kills herself in the
fairytale cuz the man doesn't water
[Laughter]
saved in the Golden Age of Disney music
music which won Oscars yes music which
is music edwin Oscar saying the music is
at least 50% of that movie of course
it's memorable it's such a phenomenal
movie the faculty we call it mediocre is
story not mediocre when it's just about
a girl that wants to get a Little
Mermaid that makes it great is Ursula
the animators inspire firstly by John
Waters Devine listen you guys are
focusing on the mediocre part but I'm
saying it's benefitted the most from
nostalgia interns don't tell me that a
movie that runs for an entire day on
three networks has not benefited more
from nostalgic people remember look I
have no idea that I ran for a holiday of
course you know my granny was gonna die
but we sat we watched a Christmas story
so I loved it
nobody knows anybody in that movie
except for Peter Dylan are you buying
any well you don't know who they are
McGavin the fact that you that you
didn't put in yours is the reason that
Christmas story aired back to back to
back to late that was because so cheap
times they dare do it because it can so
it's for time it's a wonderful life was
thought to be in public domain and
Turner aired that for 24 hours a day and
then they found a copyright was still
intact and that's why it only airs on
NBC now because Turner was like well
again on that Christmas movie what
Christmas movie do I have any reason to
a bucket and cloth exactly that is
random and that
mediocre movies that somehow we've had
Jam down our throats and now we have
come to love we can quote but how is it
benefited from how was it validated
nobody would have ever found this thing
it was gone it disappeared if it's not
like it's something because and
everything but one gay so in 80's that
was not a good thing but on the thing
about a Christmas story is with
nostalgia nostalgia means Owen
remembering something I have happy
memories this is on every year we don't
need there is no nostalgia for because
it's never been away long enough to get
nostalgia we see it all the time
Ghostbusters is an influential movie
that has nostalgia for it but go back
and watch it and it's just not it's a
fine movie it's perfectly enjoyable but
it doesn't deserve this cult of
personality that has around it Brian can
you talk about Ghostbusters and why you
think that that choice I mean Bill
Murray alone the I just I don't know I
don't know how it's yours and we're just
gonna go with that but the National Film
registry has it because of its cultural
and historic significance yes it's
something that we saw when we were
children home Christmas stories in the
National Forum right III know why
because it was on television no one
remembered it if it had just come out
beyond a year for 24 hours a day and no
one remember when I go he's like some of
the greatest comedians and one of the
best comic directors coming together and
making a film that changed everything
there wouldn't been the uproar over the
all-female one if it hadn't been
fantastic people wouldn't have cared it
would have been forgotten but the fact
is you cannot have Harold Ramis I mean
I'm not gonna go through the whole thing
by Fran I feel like Ghostbusters does
benefit most from nostalgia but I don't
feel that it is a mediocre film so I
think you have one piece of the puzzle
alright maybe you think I have one piece
of the puzzle
[Laughter]
I'll start singing that one that one was
quite funny you guys had some very
strong opinions and very educated points
of view on YouTube
we have sax for a Christmas story coming
in at 45% mod with ghostbusters I'm
breanne The Little Mermaid 17% I already
have my own what was mine please there's
a this happens for the poor 36%
that was mine 40 to 45 Candace what's
your thoughts he would you choose I mean
I think Sasha we were marrying each
other spaces during that a lot I mean
you can't talk to a little merger right
now open hi yeah I tried having an open
mind with those two but they couldn't
convince me that those were meeting
their film benefit I know so many people
that have that stupid leg lamp and they
haven't even seen it yeah it's that old
thing and that movie and I want the lamp
Wow and Jack what what hey would you go
in um there's a no man made of favorite
films of Mines I've never seen a
Christmas Story
[Applause]
well they're not gonna catch you because
you're on a mission from God I'm gonna
go with Mark and Drake because although
I personally do not think that this film
is a mediocre movie it is not about my
thoughts and the things that I do feel
with enough of slow down on ghostbusters
so I thought that you guys successfully
brought each other down but I didn't
hear enough about why Ghostbusters cuz
it's one that I mean I can feel like you
won the coin toss by the way nice you
weren't you infer that means we have sex
with one point mark with two and Brienne
with one and then we go into number five
who goes the overall best performances
from the 1980s and we are gonna start
with you Brienne Oh excellent I'm going
with Meryl Streep let's just talk a
little bit about her she had 11 films
come out in the 1980s one was released
each year two in 82 and two and 85 she
had six nominations one win for Sophie's
Choice she was nominated for the French
Lieutenant's woman Silkwood out of
africa ironweed a cry in the darks and
Sophie's Choice and this was her prime
this was she was in her 30s when this
decade was happening and so she was
getting some really great opportunities
to play different characters and I also
learned in terms of her prime let me go
over some of her other decades so in the
70s she had two nominations one win the
90s she had four nominations zero wins
in the rows four nominations zero wins
in the tens up to now she's had four
nominations and one win I feel that this
was her personal best and there is a
article that was called if she was on
the cover of Newsweek and it said and
the cover said rise to stardom so this
was really her time I also learned from
your book backwards and in heels Alicia
once you hit 40 in the 90s that's when
she started getting other offers for
roles like as witches and the older
women and she just felt like that was
kind of when maybe things started to go
a little bit downhill for her
alright Sasha I already I was sorry out
good for my Meryl Streep is absolutely
great actress but I think of an actor
who gave the best performances of the
80s including what is arguably on most
critics list the best performance of all
time and film is Robert DeNiro in the
80s he started with Raging Bull did King
of Comedy which is my personal favorite
Martin Scorsese film if you haven't seen
it go watch King of Comedy it is
timeless I just saw it at the ArcLight
Ford with Jerry Lewis it's fantastic
he did The Untouchables he Terry
Gilliam's Brazil he was in Midnight Run
one of the best underrated comedies of
that decade he was an angel heart
playing the devil with Mickey Rourke
just a great performance he was also one
once upon a time in America when you
have when you have a guy like De Niro
who is arguably equal to Meryl Streep as
far as awards and accolades and
nominations and that thing Raging Bull
is a masterclass I don't know any actor
who hasn't watched Raging Bull to see
how he did that how he immersed himself
now talking about today all these people
have become kind of pale comparisons on
the missoula I mean he did rocky and
bullwinkle and he's done whatever the
last 12 movies he did Meryl Streep is
doing a sequel to Mamma Mia Shell's it
achievable in the 80s so it all balances
up but in these decades in this decade
Robert De Niro's roles are so diverse
and and once again well you have a guy
that can do midnight run Raging Bull and
the untouchables and King of Comedy in
the same decade that the versatility
there is just unheralded and he's one of
the patron saints of actors all right so
here's my thing I feel like both you
guys are like I can literally go through
a million decades and I give you like
well Meryl Streep is the best actress of
the 90s or mm or of the 70s and I could
say the same thing about Robert De Niro
I can go through their filmography and I
can always argue that they gave the best
overall performances when I thought
about this I thought about somebody who
could really had one peak and then it
turned into Spin City and that is
Michael J Fox and I am sorry but you
cannot tell me that Marty McFly is not
one of the best performances of the 80s
he how he can talk about here
for it but he also had Star Wars and
they did all kinds of stuff now and he's
still living his dream well Michael G
Fox
fully peaked in the 80s and then it was
kind of over and when I talk about
peaked I'm talking about the fact that
Mark and drink it was dressed as him go
back to the future dress okay you've
been quoting it since we got here where
we're going there is Aaron C that is the
influence of Michael J Fox because he
wasn't just Alex P Keaton drivers remain
you [ __ ] stock of eighties Kingdom and
it wasn't just that he was this
incredible like Marty McFly pop culture
symbol he also brought brilliant
physical comedy and the secret of my
success the moment where he conducts his
neighbor's having orgasms is still one
of my favorite Michael J Fox moments
ever on screen
he stood up against Sean Penn 1980s
crazy ass Sean Penn in casualties of war
as the moral compass of that movie oh
you're the one who saw that he stood his
ground against Sean Penn because his
performance was that good he went to the
depths of drug addiction and alcoholism
in bright lights big city and even found
a way to be a believable rock star
opposite a June jet Joan mother and jet
in light of day hi my next time that you
go and it's one of the most iconic
characters yes at the 80s but also of
other decades I love Meryl Streep I love
Robert De Niro but you can't tell me
that taxi driver Godfather to deer
hunter Goodfellas heat beats out Raging
Bull because they're just as good
they've always been great Meryl Streep
you've got postcards from the edge
bridges Madison County the drag
Delaware's product doubt Iron Lady Deer
Hunter Kramer vs Kramer Michael J Fox
I'm gonna dive in here and talked about
talk to Sasha for a couple of things one
she said she's her argument with Michael
J Fox could do one thing and did one
thing well he gave a performance is
marty mcfly he had one thing I said he's
one decade she said one bank then after
that you jumped on to all these other
movies that he did so I didn't know if
he could only do one thing Marty McFly
refers to the way she presented her
answer the question she said Marty McFly
that was her whole thing that is a
performance that's not I said he created
one of the most iconic characters hence
the fact that you guys are dressed as it
and what I said was because of him there
are people who went on to great things
there are people who have had incredible
careers when you think about the 1980s
people who peaked people who truly
personified that decade are you telling
me that you're that you think Meryl
Streep personified the 1980s because I
don't think so when you win that's when
you're judging and that's a question you
ask we can answer that question
in the word mock what did you think
about mouth straight
I think Meryl Streep was a phenomenal
actress and I think the Meryl Streep is
especially in the 80s was was really
great and had a lot of stuff in the 90s
my problem with Meryl Streep is that
this is a fault of the industry that she
played a lot of accents she played a lot
of a lot of ethereal Karen a lot of and
she brought so much to it Sophie's
Choice is one of my favorite movies of
all time I watch it once a year it's a
beautiful powerful just cathartic movie
but as far as like when I when you talk
about actors in the 80s who had impact
Raging Bull is not as all is always up
in the top two or three with Citizen
Kane on these lists of the best American
films ever made
and Robert De Niro's performance is
cited by you show me an actor who hasn't
seen it I'll show you someone who
doesn't not happen what do you think
- beer well I feel like Robert De Niro's
decade that he really came into his own
with the 90s I mean I would really
disagree with that yeah because I
haven't seen like half of these films he
didn't win Oscars in the nineties but he
did good in the 90s and he was nominated
for awakenings and Cape Fear so he had
more nominations there than he did in
the 80s for what he was nominated for
regional he was nominee for the king of
comedy he was nominated for the
untouchables in performance I mean Judi
Dench one roster so what you're
basically basing this off of Raging Bull
and that's it well Raging Bull is the
way to start and then the rest of the
80s the diversity of the product that he
did there the diversity of the roles all
right and what do you think about micro
tech [ __ ] yeah Fran Michael J Fox I mean
I really loved him in that TV movie
poison ivy and I wish that was you know
that's a different film that you
remember it was a summer camp film facts
of life know I remembered Skippy Marty
McFly I loved that performance but it's
one performance and that's really all I
noticed him for from the 80s all right
final thoughts Esha what do you thing
about that choices and yours okay I
think that Robert De Niro and Meryl
Streep you literally talk about lifetime
achievements and you can pick any decade
and they've given incredible
performances I think we're totally
devaluing the fact that one of the
hardest things for an actor to do is be
simple and be true and be like somebody
who you want to welcome into your heart
all of these are very showy parts
Michael J Fox when he's Alex pilling
so he just had to do like a that's
Cher's movie
now he cracked open America's heart and
everybody wanted to be his friend
everybody wanted to be his boyfriend
everybody wanted to know him everybody
wanted to be near him there is something
about simplicity that I think you guys
are overrated and there's also the fact
that it wasn't just that he was Marty
McFly Bright Lights Big City is a very
dark really tormented movie casualties
of war it is so difficult to be the
emotional centerpiece of a film and
that's a dark brutal war movie with Sean
freaking Pantera shooing soon scenery
Matt it's harder than you think
if those performances were so profound
and so groundbreaking and connected with
so many people why did those movies make
zero dollars at the box office and no
future because Marty McFly Back to the
Future is one of is one of the best best
films of all time and one of the best
scripts of all time it's a way to make a
crowd-pleasing movie but as you said it
was one great performance and everything
he did beyond that was various degrees
and the one we tried to go too far
outside of it it was bright lights big
city which is an interminably dull film
or light of day which even though I'm an
extra in it is an insufferable film and
in Meryl Streep
you know Meryl Streep has been
consistently good since the 70s she has
had a couple of a couple of till the 80s
I mean the seventies a certain role
she's still today even though her
choices are less interesting she's still
a really great actor De Niro peaked in
the eighties he had all that great stuff
in the 70s and then you have once again
Raging Bull is the pinnacle of his
career and then you have Midnight Run
you're having scene doing comedy you
have King you have king of comedy
you haven't getting Oscar nominations
for five or ten minutes in a movie is
he's just there was just the peak of his
pearly powers he had a couple hits in
the 90s but the rest of it has been Meet
the Fockers
you know I think that Meryl Streep is
this is the peak of her in the 80s and
especially with Sophie's Choice where
she did the theme the choice scene only
one time only one take she said it was
too painful and too emotionally draining
for her and she wasn't gonna be able to
do it any other time and just to be able
to get it all in one cut not only with
her but the other actors around her and
for her to make them feel that they you
know that she could carry this and that
you know difficult
oh sure sure but that I lost what I was
going to say but I do want to fact-check
myself because that Newsweek headline
was a star for the 80s and not rise to
stardom so good alright Jack
fact-checker
how amazing Awards did you say DeNiro
one for Raging Bull won Best Actor for a
second yeah that I'm sorry I thought you
said how many times he was nominee he
was nominee for fees in the eighties for
an Academy Award no he was only
nominated no yeah I think you through it
but for an Academy Award all I have is
him one for Raging Bull well he did get
nominate Kim King of Comedy oh sure yeah
that's right what do people saying on on
YouTube do they have a consensus is a
tough one as well we thought the
Ghostbusters you do your choice in the
no gift
okaycome breakdowns the polls all right
well well yeah it's a tough one again I
thought you all had pretty good
arguments about why they had great
performances within the 80s but in terms
of talking about how diverse the
performances were in the 80s this
doesn't help my judging at all but
marking some points which means yards or
you get a glove because I liked the way
you talked about how Robert De Niro did
so much with in the 80s because the
question is overall best performances
Sasha I thought you know I love my fans
but they
but it was just about talking about what
she did with in the eighties that made
her so special
yes so and a baby's mark on three such
on one Briana one before we get to it
Jack what was the consensus words all I
have for that is Raging Bull one
nomination really well even on Wikipedia
doesn't say that fire fact checkers say
yes well I'm the computers the factory
of what we're saying is let's go in last
place with Brienne with Mary to 21% a
very close second place I think I won
one of these because I was actually a
teenager in okay so that means we have
to do a tiebreaker between Sasha Brienne
yeah
your mother effort so what I'm gonna do
for that I'm gonna throw a speed round
question at you both to a quick speed
round between you two just for the one
of who's gonna go around to the real
speed round so Jack if you can be ready
for the time problem you'd walk 20
seconds for the initial argument from
each one then 10 seconds from each
rebuttal dot it and so make sure you
buzz me when it gets to 20 so the
question for the tiebreaker is what is
okay who is the best member of the Brat
Pack molly ringwald tom d'arnot emilio
estevez
20 seconds to you now molly ringwald was
the exemplification of teenage 80s prom
queen across sixteen Candles pretty in
pink
Breakfast Club she was the girl we all
wanted to be and she wasn't not just
like a lot of the rest of them she never
got into a bad way she was a fantastic
actress and it's just because she's a
girl that she doesn't have a better
career which is heartbreaking but when
you think of her she was the queen all
right brand and a million west of us was
the king that's pretty much all I have
no um I was thinking of it about this
more in terms of seeing him after at the
brat pack so I don't know if that would
design that because I loved him in
Mighty Ducks and I find that I
appreciate him in his older years as
eight and there's such things
all right my time is up and thank you
nobody does nothing to be with a brat
pack when you think about the brat pack
the person I think of his Molly Ringwald
and I think about her and all of her
glory Emilio Estevez was a supporting
character at best I think the Judge
Nelson probably or even Anthony Michael
Hall Anthony Michael Hall
I mean you know why Molly Ringwald's
career hit the tongue the dumps because
there's no because she said in a Time
magazine interviewed she was on the
cover she made she insulted John Hughes
and that's when stuff using her because
she turned 40 and then she got all the
which winds you don't have time to bleed
because you're gonna stay round so let's
get into it this is your chance for five
more points you know how it works
give me in the event of an either/or
question who have answers first we'll
get to get that answe on the other
person asks you by default take the
other answer first person to answer gets
to go first twenty seconds as your
initial argument ten second rebuttal
let's kick it off with the first
question what is the best John Hughes
movie Brooks it's Ferris Bueller's Day
Off
all right mug you have it fest fires
ready yes as my illustrious competition
said earlier in the show today she
listed all the reasons that Breakfast
Club was great The Breakfast Club
defines a generation of youth The
Breakfast Club is a very specific movie
about a specific time he got five
amazing performances from unknown actors
at that time Molly Amy wrote arguably
was on facts of life before that and
it's a movie that is timeless because of
its specificity you can be a teenager
today on the Block Joe alright
session fillers Bueller's Day Off does
more than create great teenage roles
which John Hughes was so known for it
also it's fantasy wish fulfillment in
the best possible way and John Hughes at
his best was amplified and this is one
of the best performances he ever got out
of one of his actors I truly believe
Matthew Broderick as Ferris Bueller is
beyond iconic yes all five of the people
in The Breakfast Club are great but I
think Matthew Broderick's performance
Trump's all of them oh ten seconds I
think it comes down to that being a
really great comedy that's a little
wacky and it's all about a once again
John Hughes's fort a rich white kids
where this movie where The Breakfast
Club is a very human movie that
transcends the races of the kids and the
socioeconomic status
and has a thing that connects to souls I
completely disagree with you I think
Ferris Bueller connects but also you've
got Charlie Sheen you've got Jennifer
Grey you've got all of these other
elements that give you the sides of
personality you're talking about and you
got dancing in the streets and that is
the best part that's a good question I'm
gonna go for mark because of the
diversity of the backgrounds of the kids
in and we want to see that on-screen
yourselves so many good points from all
of them Candace what do you think
actually I would think Breakfast Club
but I actually am feeling more Ferris
Bueller's it's a little more memorable
different parts of it alright Jack based
on the arguments what do you think
breakfast up just because at the movie
that it wasn't a all right well I'm
gonna go based on the arguments and not
my thoughts I'm gonna go with The
Breakfast Club mark gets a point because
I like the way you talked about their
backgrounds and you talked about how it
defined a generation but sash you did
such a good job and I agree that it's
such a great performance from Matthew
Broderick so it makes like a charwoman
Mary Poppins the next question I'll give
you a bump of coke oh then I get it
right it helps with this big round I'm
sure
second question if they remade die hard
today who should play Hans Gruber oh oh
god there's one answer it's a horrible
answer gary oldman health man says mom i
don't want anybody else to play and I
just love Alan [ __ ] so much yeah
let's go with the Drewes Alba
fat second mark and drink oh I'm gonna
go out without aiming towards
going on here
mock you get to go first
gary gary oldman is one of the most
versatile actors we alive on the planet
he's gonna get an Oscar nomination this
year for playing wooden mist and
Churchill Gary Oldman has played nice
guys has played evil guys has played
foreign guys he's played vampires he's
played guys in the future he was in he
was in the Lupus on movie he's just a
great versatile actor and he can do
sinister so well I would believe that he
would be that Eurotrash sort of guy okay
we've totally seen Alan Rickman do it
now in Rickman wood or Gary Oldman would
just be a weak ripoff of that I want to
see something different I want to see a
sexy hans gruper I want to see Hans
Gruber who makes me want to cheer
because the thing that makes sounds
river so great it's it's a feeling you
love to hate and I want to see it
yourself but go to the dark side on that
stuff Gary Oldman is just the same thing
it would just be a sad recreation and
the whole time you'd be like I was this
was Alan Rickman she suddenly she did a
bump of coke on I think I think the
blanket dismissal of Gary Oldman is the
same thing as in defiance of his great
filmography where he's done Sid Vicious
and he's done Dracula and he's done
Winston Churchill this guy is so
versatile he would be evocative of the
original performance but he will make it
his own I think you're just racist and
you don't want to see a diversity
it's great but we've seen it we've done
it like something new we need new blood
new blood Idris Elba is that new blood
Oh guys so Jack what are you thinking
well I was like hey yeah we open because
he's engaged but then she was like if
yourself but he's what something do
sounds like so now not much choice solve
everything yourself oh yeah and I want
to see Gary Oldman as Hans Gruber's so
badly and I love Alan Rickman but that
would be fine
bran what do you think um I don't think
you're racist
[Laughter]
sorry west of us all right I like that
yeah both your arguments but I did I did
like how you said that it could be a
shade of something that we've already
seen from Gary Oldman and we haven't
seen this from Idris Elba so that makes
our gets a point four points to three
this very deciding choice is mark would
not give me a fifth bomb I'm racist here
we go be third yeah 42 whoa oh okay I
was counting this tiebreaker oh yeah OOP
Billy says it's 42 so now number three
I'm in a must-win situation this whole
time there is law what to present-day
actors which to present actors should
start in a remake of twins
to present-day access actually regards
twins between the two Kevin Hart in the
rock Oh gross that movie just makes me
vomit and it just was Greenlee at the
moment I said it is shortened dave
bautista you know and Zac Efron oh all
right Mike he gets to go first again
we've already seen that the rock and
Kevin Hart had great chemistry and as
ridiculous as the visual of Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Danny DeVito is the
visual of the rock and Kevin Hart who
could literally fit into the rocks
breast-pocket
is even funnier and playing up the
racial diversity of both of them one is
I believe Samoan and Hawaiian and you
have an african-american how are you
going to explain that that's gonna be
that can be a ridiculous way of eugenics
we've seen this movie so many times we
don't need to see it again it would just
be a retread the thing about Dave
Bautista is he's a really fantastic
actor which we see consistently and
guardians of the galaxy and Zac Efron
playing his doofy brother would be
absolutely hilarious he's a fantastic
straight man Dave Bautista and Zac Efron
likes going to physical comedy and
that's the thing that I think we need we
already know what that movie is Mark's
movies been done and it sucks wow she's
being racist cuz I have a black I think
I think dismissing it because we've seen
these two act together is
counterintuitive because we've seen
Martin Scorsese and Robert De Niro do
movies together into Johnny Depp and by
throwing people away they work together
freak Utah compare Martin Scorsese
that's just off track but the thing
about Dibattista and Zac Efron is they
would have great comedic chops together
they would bring a sexiness that we
wouldn't expect and I think Dave
Bautista needs a starved banking vehicle
and this to be a
Oh Brianne I'm going Sasha on this one I
want to see something different I feel
like we've seen this one before many
times Central Intelligence Jumanji it's
continuing from man crush Monday every
Monday alongside Channing Tatum they
were my go to them in having Kevin Hart
out of the rock of Purim Peter Dinklage
instead which one of those two would you
like to I want to do the one more
interesting fact Kevin Hart in the rock
has such a great chemistry together yeah
they are funny together and I like
Central Intelligence for what it was but
I'm gonna give it to Sasha because I
like the way you talked about today but
James I love and the straight man
physical comedy and sexiness as well all
right so that means mock for Sasha three
number four which 80s movie would be
better if it were directed by Michael
Bay oh oh oh that hurts like I feel sick
yeah can we both say we don't want to
answer okay Joanne again the next time
all right so which two movie characters
would you want to take a ferris bueller
style day off with which may be carried
is Ferris Bueller no you can if you like
wait but any two movie characters
characters have a day off where you do
all the world will go from the 80s
Oh
yes oh my god good I need about it give
some time tell me when you cut okay fine
Johnny Castle wait now keep going I'm
already excited
I make tapes back I might take those
back and change it no Doc Brown from
Back to the Future mm-hmm and Charlie
Sheen from Wall Street Pacific finance
everything Johnny Council and gizmo oh
good smoke all right so she you answered
that one first with your first pick
Johnny Castle so you get to go first
okay obviously first things first Johnny
Castle and I have to dance all over the
city gizmo and I are going to eat a ton
of the things before it gets to midnight
we're gonna have so much fun exploring
all the things in Chicago which is a
fantastic City we each have to make sure
we stay away from the river hi I'm
Johnny castle doing anything with me
would be the greatest moment of my life
and I don't even feel like I can answer
this question cuz now I'm just living at
Kellerman's and gizmo is there and we're
best friends and we cuddle Doc Brown
would be the best tour guide ever
because he's been to the future he's a
little time machine the day off with him
would be going through different
different eras going all over the world
and we're gonna need money to get the
uranium to power this thing in Charlie
Sheen greed is good all that money he
had in Wall Street and he had some good
drugs so we're gonna get to do some
bumps we're gonna get to have pay for
everything and we're gonna be traveling
for the future with the best tour guide
ever all right drugs are bad you
shouldn't do drugs and the thing about
Johnny Cash it's not about where you go
you don't need a good tour guide you
don't need your a name you don't need a
bunch of money all you need is great
companionship in gizmo and Johnny Castle
are the best companionship that money
doesn't even need to buy because it's
not love
hanging out with a middle-aged man who's
dating a 15 year old girl and the
Poconos is kind of creepy and you can't
take your pet out after dark or feed it
after midnight or get it wet so it's
gonna stink Brianne this could be the
deciding vote pandering sorry this is
the pandering vijaya like I'm a dancer
this is my day Sasha this is my day I
want to learn the Mambo two arguments
achoo per person I should definitely go
with the funding money and don't brown
as a toe would and Kenda I mean you have
Patrick's lazy and fluffy so it's just
like everything I want any day everyone
said the exact same thing as well mocks
at that which was like gizmos just like
you can't do anything but you go before
dark I know and that is exactly why I'm
gonna give mock the point
the point about yes with a creepy guy
they should smell off the duck it's
gonna be a nightmare surprises
[Applause]
[Music]
or st. Elmo's fire yeah well so that
means mock you got five second you got
three such a great fight I think I
barely managed to keep control but I try
lunches but win ruin movie fights is
definitely not for wimps so
congratulations to all of you let's go
down the line and say where you can find
you so Brianne what can people find more
about it yeah and you can find me all
day every day on Twitter at miss movies
you can also find me on a youtube
channel youtube.com slash miss movies
where I have a show called film therapy
where we talk about how films affect our
lives
Mac you can find me at mark and draco on
twitter the first issue of Harley Quinn
and poison ivy meet Betty and Veronica
written by me and Paul Dini who created
Harley Quinn comes out Wednesday super
fun and super ridiculous and love is
love just won another award for best I
feel like a $225,000 Wow oh it's so
great Sasha you can find me on Twitter
and Instagram at Sasha Pearl River and
if you want to see pictures of the
cutest cat ever
swazey you can see me every Friday on FX
movie download at 8 p.m. on FX
well done you all fought such a good job
and this was John great Jack I threw you
into the deep end there with some tough
tough fact-checking and about YouTube
going crazy so you guys thank you for
joining us where can people find you you
can find me at Jack hug on Twitter of
course as always and thank you so much
for having you guys everybody in the
YouTube comments you and their hilarious
and logo like that's like so much fun
watching it live and people can see you
on Fandango yes
today and Candace me thank you so much
for joining us why can people find you
on Twitter
Candace Leon Smith straight forward I
also blog got now never ends calm Oh
awesome thanks so much for being on the
fan cam and participating in the outfits
you can find me at Alicia Malone
remember be excellent to each other boy
gets fantastic
brought to you by t-mobile
now family plans include Netflix at no
extra charge another reason why t-mobile
is America's best unlimited network
[Music]
you